hey everyone i'm aaron taylor johnson
and i'm brian terry henry get your
tickets now to see our new movie bullet
train oh that's a that was a bit
demanding wasn't it
what we'll get your tickets now was a
bit demanding that's not demanding i'm
letting everyone know that tickets for
bullet train are available literally
right now mm-hmm well you know tomato
tomato i guess
you mean tomato tomato who says tomato
we all say it differently well you just
say it wrongly you know
just be polite about the tickets
get your tickets for bullet train as
soon as it's convenient for you please
well no you know don't wait too long
because fiat is you know they might sell
out and spoil as much surface or any
number of those things might happen so
you know now would be
preferable so so polite is unreal well
turmarto say that let me someone say
never saying that you can buy them on
fandango right now yeah or is it fandom
it is definitely
i mean
obviously there's a right answer to that
[Music]
you